on April seventeenth 2012 film courage
attended the roundtable press interview
for the meg and lawrence kasdan film
darling companion this audio contains an
interview with ayelet zurer who plays
carmen and mark Duplass who plays brian
in the film for more information on
darling companion please visit sony
classics calm forward slash darling
companion like a big whirlwind here for
you if you have so many projects coming
out kind of faced in between money
Stephanie ejector was at home did you
'deck up and a lot of itself by
Southwest safety not guaranteed your
sister sister people like us bottle over
it ends there baby what's it been like
for you like everything coming out you
know it does seem like things of
bottlenecked a little bit you know but
it wasn't like I did all these movies
last year they're all done of the course
of the last couple of years so hasn't
been that crazy in terms of the workload
but it's definitely you know when you
say it like that it certainly sounds
surreal do I perfume have any great dog
stories all you dog lovers could you
rescued any dogs have you rescued and on
sale I did um I have a 70 year old kid
and he always wanted a dog and I wasn't
brave enough to take one but when we
filmed this movie we shot in the shelter
and I thought to myself okay so I'm not
taking a dog from this shelter where I'm
actually put there and then I'll never
actually do it and we went in there were
only big dogs yeah big scary dogs and
the back the hell does a little puppy
the only talking to have and I took it
so now i have a pretty system and so I
specifically was looking for something
very tiny so I could carry with me not
very tiny because I don't like those
handbags you are going to go oh boy so I
asked like a Jeff Russell maybe
something like
I said it's a Jack Russell and it's a
mini calling and um I took it home and
then I had to go to Israel actually for
a job for a short time we all flown in
somebody took care of the dog he came
back in and the dog was this data within
two weeks he just had grown too massive
what we love it how'd you have any
psychic skills in love me no I'm afraid
I died I wish i ad but I don't see her
just as a psychic i thought that common
just had a bigger larger capacity for
other people's feelings and that's what
she's about really she just really wants
harmony and love and she just had that
thing more than like a normal person you
know and so if she gives him something
off intensely our good intentions of
that again exact you know that's like a
off like too much baby yeah so you will
let the schedule because it's lawrence
kasdan yes yeah i would never work for
you midst I mean you know what I would
have paid scale to be on this movie yeah
I'm not kidding always said that you
know I mean you hope that a movie
delivers two out of three components
which are a good script good cast and
good director you know and this was very
clearly three out of three weeks for our
taste you know and I oh and I've very
quickly formed a bond as those being
indicted by the other cast members you
know we showed up were like oh sure you
know but it was so fun I mean we shot
for six weeks and you know that was
beautiful time of year and Utah so you
know independent films are not often
that glamorous in terms of having a
great place to be with great people and
we would have these ion and I kept
taking catch members out to dinners
every time we did we would get a new
Woody Allen story or a new like you know
Richard Jenkins running this theater
troupe
more shakes eff yeah it was crazy you
know we were we were lucky so he's been
told that scary movie Oh swell work we
did we spend it all in general insurance
right yeah you have so many talents
between writing and directing and acting
and me to get Jason Segel this weekend
so wait which do you prefer I love all
the things that that I do and I think
that in particular for acting in
particular for a project like this to
have someone else at the helm who's so
specific about his vision and lawrence
and and also medic you know with the
scripts they just know what they want
and we were kind of there to serve their
purpose and that is not only really fun
forum antics of pressure off but it's a
great attitude to the filmmaking process
as a director where you're you know
living with it for two years constantly
stressed out trying to you know nuance
the tones of the film this is going to
be creative for 10 12 hours a day and
walk away but he's also very humble cuz
meantime you know he was working on
three project in the trailer he writes
really fast it was unbelievable to see
for my you know point of view I learned
a lot from you austere we were I oh I
were hatched projects together yeah but
we did some punches doctor here's a
quick quick cut creator and you have
noticed a big project this year not
matter scale I mean yeah how do you feel
finger guns we love interest to mom but
that's interesting actually um oh you
know these two project couldn't be
different from one another we have the
budget the directors their sensitivity
their approach I have a pseudomonas
quality yeah the one glasses yeah
jerk I'm not all geeks I'll wondering
what look at a thing that we could've
that's my participation in this matter
sphere on your brain Laura it looks
closer you know I can't say much but it
looks closer from what I've seen to the
darkness of dark night because don't
forget who is also executive producing
this thing so it has a very dark feeling
to it and more hmm lets us superhero
just you know black and white child for
Superman it's gonna be a little edgier
I'd say how do you put your Laura what's
your approach on there I never wanna be
ya hey Mel trouble yeah I getting
trouble um but she plays it really well
it was enjoyable and I loved working
with director and also waived them my
fellow actors that was the interesting
bit very different I'm don't feel bad
she doesn't tell me anything he liked to
launch an oz after Russia she's like
when you get those things like I'm not
necessarily a dog I mean you basically
most on fate you know like that like
signs or like dude well look how do you
do it start trying to find something of
you been doing to you my process as I
stay and I stay on the the earthly side
of my brain for a very very long time I
followed all the empirical steps no one
I would have lost something I don't I
stay I stay where was I last I go check
the car I checked the car twice i start
looking in the refrigerator what you
know the whole the whole thing and then
something usually turns over on me you
know and then i'll start to think i was
raised Catholic you know everything
about like isn't there some st. i'm
supposed to pray to finds things if
they're doing all those things you know
and then I you know this is corny but I
I believe there's a certain symmetry to
like the process of surrender and that
that can also
bring those things back to you and I
think that's a lot what you know the
characters and darling companion are
dealing with which is you know Joseph
played by Kevin Kahn is a very tenacious
guy i'm a very tenacious guy or type a
and while Joseph is experiencing the
laws of this dog at the troubles with
his marriage i'm experiencing this like
kind of crazy explosive new woman in my
life it's these intangible elements that
shake us up and then kind of bring us
back to our course somehow what what you
want what do you do when you lose
something that's endearing view I listen
to my first thought it's always the
first thought I feel like you should
listen to because that's the thing that
you should follow and then the brain
comes in it's like I do believe that
there's two parts of our brains and each
one is responsible to some other thing
and and so the one that responsible for
her logic is the one you should not
listen to when you lose things or when
you need to listen to your intuition or
something it's not that part of the ring
you don't want to do that you want to
listen to the other one that comes first
and then being shut up by the logic few
most people don't trust that so that's
the thing should and I learned to do
that I I have to say that I did I do
this it's not enough I just leaves that
it's it's not an easy one and sometimes
you've been taught that by misfortunes
or like tougher experiences but if you
do listen to that you learn to trust
that and it's weird because I now use it
for other things which is ridiculous I
used to forget passwords I could just
could not remember any passwords into my
computer and so it's really annoying to
fumble through your personal occur and
everybody's in line and you need to
press that thing or whatever and and and
since I made a decision like a logic
decision to listen to that first thought
I remember every single class one that I
have and they're complicated
but i do remember them they comfort will
mark when you're working on a film like
this with somebody like lawrence kasdan
do you when you're not doing the acting
part do you kind of watch and I do yeah
I mean I hadn't haven't worked with an
epic director like this before you know
work with noah baumbach on Greenberg and
he's you know pretty amazing but maybe
more appear to a certain extent Ryan's
Kazon is is a screen the legend grew up
watching his movies and and so for me I
was absolutely curious to shadow as much
as i could and see what his ideas and
techniques were and what I kind of
discovered which was interesting was
that I think part of the reason he
wanted me on set was because I had a lot
of experience independent sphere and
this was his first independent film you
know in terms of making your dollar
stretch little tricks like that here and
there so I learned a lot about efficient
screenwriting from him and how to do big
things with very few words because i'm
just a very verbose person my art and
then every now and then i would actually
have something that i could teach them
or the production you know where we're
like trying to set the camera rigs up in
the car the lights going down we don't
have enough time like how are we going
to get this cuz they're thinking 3599
maybe budgets and you know i can kind of
be like I can actually know how to shoot
this mad so it was cool I felt like a
couple of times so my other experiences
were useful what was your best large
captain movie that you saw old old one
that affected you the most big too yeah
yeah one that really got me let me keep
flexing on tourists okay because I was I
think I was about ten when that movie
came out and it's about the death of the
Sun and so for some reason I was a
perfect age to see since the sun went
away I immediately was like well Who am
I going to watch in this movie
went to the parents which you don't
identify with that was a ten-year-old
normal you know but they're right about
my parents age you know and I was just
like oh my god I can really feel this
feeling in adults perspective you know
for a young kid is just a strange thing
what was it about League trophy okay
people stuck together and how they are
perceived in a group I think something
to do with identity I can't quite put my
finger on it but i think its identity
and i think what's beautiful about how
he writes is that he really is
incredible with putting different voices
two characters which is something you
don't tend to see very much in
screenplays and Hollywood's fix
screenplays you know it's always the
same voice but with different aspect of
the same boys kind of thing but you know
you hear the writer and all of the
voices Wendy like oh he's writing
something but you don't hear ya they're
different so it in what's amazing is the
voices are different they're actually
different the it doesn't sound like the
same person speaking and you can totally
see that because we had um table reads
we have team of weeds and you know at
the beginning you don't have a lot of
presentation of the characters and the
actor ISM but when you just have to the
words lyrics you know yeah very strong
it can really sense it which is amazing
about his he's there they're writing
jobs acting like to yeah we're not a
question of it what do you hope
audiences take away from feel-good movie
you know that's what they should take
away love good not mine I guess what I
love about the movie is that it's is
about a family that is not too
dissimilar from a lot of families on
that on certainly not that different
from my family that's got their fair
share of issues and resentments and
problems but like most families there
often just one step away from
reconnecting as much as it seems like
everything's crumbling this dog was the
linchpin have kept them all together and
and so it's that feeling of like it
might feel sucky a lot of the time for
you and your family but you're very
close probably to something I visit
greatness get some lunch I I guess